The problem with shopping for strollers...
...is that babies can't talk to tell you what they like.
How are the ergonomics in the stroller?
And an adult certainly can't fit into a baby stroller.
Feels like a smooth ride, but that's all speculation, right?
You don't know 'cause you're not the baby.
I know.
You're not a baby in a stroller.
Right.
We created an exact, adult-size replica of one of our best-selling baby strollers...
...and invited parents to try it,...
...showing just how comfortable Contours strollers are for babies.
Cozy, right?
Yeah, it's very cozy.
It's very comfortable.
I love it.
How's it feel in there, comfortable?
It's very comfortable, yeah, it's cozy.
Twinkle, twinkle, little star.
That's really nice.
Are you getting more comforted?
I am.
Here comes some sun.
Ooh, that's the sun!
Peekaboo!